-Here's how the game works.
One person puts on
these headphones
with very loud music playing.
You can play this at home.
The other person picks up a card
and reads the random phrase
on that card.
And the person
wearing headphones
has to try and guess what
the other person said.
Will, you put the headphones
on first,
and I'll read a phrase to you,
and then you'll guess
what I'm saying.
Let's make sure
the music is playing.
Can you hear me?
-No.
-Can you hear me?
-Huh?
Good.
Music's playing?
-Yeah.
-Good.
A beautiful day in the
neighborhood.
-A boot full of...
-A beautiful day --
a beautiful day --
-A boat full --
What?
-A beautiful day in the
neighborhood.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-What?!
How did you know that?
Did you peek at my card?
-No, you have
very readable lips.
-It is my turn here.
Let's see how I do.
-You do it now?
-Yeah.
-Oh, okay.
-Sorry. Oh, yeah.
I like this.
I want to download this.
-You should.
-Okay.
-Yeah? Yep, yep, yep, yep.
I have a shoplifting problem.
-I have --
-I have a serious
shoplifting problem.
Stealing makes me feel big.
-Cheddar cheese?
-I steal everything.
Groceries, books, cold medicine.
I know I'm sick,
but I can't help myself.
-Help?
-It's like a high to me.
I love the danger of
almost getting caught.
-Slow down. Slow down.
Slow down.
-Can you imagine the headlines?
"Will Ferrell arrested for
shoplifting at Kohl's."
God, that'd be so humiliating.
-Beer koozie.
-But what can I say?
It turns me on.
-Attorney at law?
I have no clue. I'm sorry.
-No, it was Baby Yoda.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I should have gotten Baby Yoda.
That's pretty famous.
You were just saying Baby Yoda
over and over?
-Do I go?
-Yeah, you go.
-Okay. You put on
the headphones.
Imposs--
-Impossible Whopper.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-How?
-It's a gift. It's a gift.
Your turn.
-Okay. Alright.
We'll do one more round.
-One more round? Okay.
-I'm feeling good about this.
Okay, let's do it. Come on.
I can do it. I can do it.
-Do you like cults?
I'm starting one,
and guess what --
you're my first member.
I've already seized
your bank accounts
and stolen your identity.
You shouldn't
leave your e-mail open.
Do you know how easy
it is to find
a Social Security number?
I'm going to erase you.
-Shush? California raisins?
-We'll worship
Jonathan Lipnicki as a God.
We're going to use your money
to build a temple
dedicated to the
Jonathan Lipnicki movie
"The Little Vampire."
And your new legal name
will be Jonathan Lopnocki,
because it's as close as we can
get to naming you
after our new God
without angering him.
-Anger management?
-I'm gonna dye your hair blond
and make you wear
little, round glasses.
And instead of "hello,"
you'll greet me by saying,
"Did you know that the human
head weighs 8 pounds?"
And then, I'll say, "Really?
Let's find out for ourselves."
And that's when I'm gonna pop
your pretty little head off
like a [bleep] dandelion.
All it takes is a dull knife
and 10 minutes.
And that's when
I take your glasses
and I put them on my own face
and then I see what God sees.
Then I see what our God,
Jonathan Lipnicki, sees.
-Then I see what our God,
Nailed it.
-Yeah!
[ Dinging ]
You got it.
-Great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We're good --
-Yeah.
-We're good at this.
Will Ferrell, everybody!
-The second time.
-That's the second time.